le porte-parole du Parti communiste
chinois donne les indications
journalistes présents pour pouvoir
couvrir le congrès du parti qui débute
dimanche un événement politique qui
revient tous les 5 ans
2300 délégués choisis par les assemblées
du parti seront présents ils se
retrouveront à huis clos pour renouveler
les dirigeants du pays mais le suspense
est presque nul
à l'aube de ses 70 ans devrait se voir
accorder un troisième mandat comme
secrétaire général du parti et comme
président de la République populaire de
Chine
ce qui va à l'encontre des règles de
succession qui avait été établies il y a
à peu près 30 ans par
D shopping à ce moment-là c'était
entendu qu'un leader pouvait comme
président ou un premier ministre pouvait
servir deux mandats donc 10 ans et
quitter si on se fie au Congrès
antérieures il faudra attendre au
lendemain de la clôture de l'événement
pour l'annonce officiel incluant
également celle du comité permanent du
bureau politique un groupe restreint de
7 à 9 hommes au sommet du pouvoir de
l'État chinois d'ici là c'est Jean Ping
fera le bilan de son dernier quinquennat
et annoncera sa feuille de route pour
les 5 prochaines années en 2017 son
discours avait duré plus de trois heures
le prochain gouvernement chinois a déjà
des défis devant lui la politique de
zéro covid imposée par Pékin est
fortement critiqué par l'OMS ne pourra
pas continuer ainsi les confinements de
draconiens tirent l'économie du pays
vers le bas les experts disent que
l'économie la croissance va être réduite
de 2% à cause de cette gestion ça le
crée aussi beaucoup de recensements au
sein de la population chinoise il y a
aussi beaucoup de compagnies étrangères
qui commencent à se dire est-ce que se
fait encore du sens de rester en Chine
et sur le dossier de Taïwan le Parti
communiste assure que le gouvernement
exercera tous ses pouvoirs pour amener
l'île sous son giron ici Carla Oliveira
Radio-Canada Montréal